moving on
our main story tonight concerns
ambulances you know
big ouchy trucks that go whoop whoop
ambulances can be an annoyance to city
dwellers with their shrieking sirens
although
not if you live in brussels where that
siren sounds very different
[Applause]
okay that is just an objectively better
siren it sounds like
mickey mouse getting on a washing
machine in a good way
and i do know that that is hard to
picture so please let me help
oh boy i mean that's fantastic i'd far
rather be woken up by the sound of
america's rats getting railed on the
spin cycle because
i'd immediately laugh then remember that
someone was having a medical emergency
and feel bad
then hear the siren and laugh myself to
sleep again
what a siren anyway ambulance crews
clearly play a critically important role
across the country so it is no wonder
that during the height of the pandemic
last year they were among those who got
an
outpouring of gratitude and nightly
applause with new york's mayor
even making this pledge i want to
guarantee you one thing
that when that day comes that we can
restart the
vibrant beautiful life of this city
again the first thing we will do
is we will have a ticker tape parade
down the canyon of heroes for our health
care workers
and our first responders we will honor
those who saved us okay first i don't
know if a parade
is quite the dangling carrot de blasio
seems to think it is because parades and
this is true
suck they are loud crowded and go on
approximately four hours too long
the only good thing about the
thanksgiving day parade is seeing which
country singer gets to lip sync next to
the jolly green giant's dick
but second there was a small irony in
all the vocal appreciation that took
place last year as this emt
that we featured pointed out right now
i'm doing all of this
with no health insurance the job doesn't
offer it
and our affordable marketplaces
aren't very affordable if i get sick
and okay i go get tested positive
i can't go to the hospital you know
people come out and they show us the
support and i love it i love
i've eaten so much pizza in the last two
weeks it's been great
i don't need pizza i need to be able to
pay my bills
right people clapping and giving pizza
in appreciation was very nice
but it wasn't a substitute for the
things that they actually needed like
a living wage and health benefits think
about it like this
if you had a heart attack and paramedics
showed up with a pepperoni pie and some
garlic knots
you'd be grateful sure but you'd also be
justified in pointing out that that's
not
everything that the situation demanded
and that man's story is by no
means a one-off ems workers around the
country are
shockingly underpaid which is kind of
amazing
especially when you consider how
prohibitively expensive
taking an ambulance can be so much so
you'll often see local news stories like
this
it was rush hour at the mass avenue
station when this
passenger stepped off the crowded train
surveillance video shows the moment her
leg dropped into the gap
trapping her between the train and the
platform as
other commuters rocked the train to
dislodge the woman's leg
a boston globe reporter tweeted from the
scene
she begged no one call an ambulance it's
three thousand dollars
i can't afford that wow it is a
pretty strong indictment of our current
health care system that that woman's
main concern was getting crushed
financially
even while she was getting crushed
physically so given that
we have injured people begging
bystanders not to call ambulances and
the emts who work inside them forced to
live off peta donations
tonight let's take a look at our
emergency medical services specifically
how they function why they can be so
expensive and
what we can do to fix things and the
first thing to know is there is
absolutely no consistency
when it comes to ems in this country
when you talk about
emergency medical services you're
actually talking about
19 000 locally run ems providers
with wildly different structures to give
you an idea of just how much variant
exists in houston
ems is provided by firefighters
cross-trained as paramedics or emts
in new york city it's under the fire
department umbrella but
it's a separate division and
supplemented by private companies
in pittsburgh it's a freestanding
municipal department of its own and in
rural wyoming
ems is mostly provided by
volunteer-based organizations and
frustratingly
in no part of the country does ems have
ambulances that sound like this
the very fact our sirens could sound
like a puccini aria
performed by a flustered parakeet and
yet we choose for that not to be the
case
makes us a bunch of idiots but
all of this is to say if you have seen
one ems set up
you've seen exactly one ems set up
and one reason for this is that there is
no single federal agency
overseeing and supporting ems in the
same way that for instance
fire departments have the u.s fire
administration
and the frustrating thing is it didn't
have to be this way
back in 1973 congress enacted the ems
systems act which created
a new program to help develop regional
ems systems something
that was badly needed prior to that
ambulance services were frequently
provided by
hearses simply because they were long
enough to transport a human body
now unfortunately under the reagan
administration budget cuts eliminated
direct federal funding and oversight
shifting the responsibility
onto the states many of which opted to
direct their money away from ems
and into other public health services
instead which brings us
to an absolutely incredible fact unlike
other first responders such as police
and fire departments right now
in all 39 of these states ems
is not considered an essential service
meaning local governments don't have to
provide it to their citizens which as a
practical matter
means ems generally has much less access
to government funding
this is a huge deal and if this is
surprising news to you
you are not alone just listen to this
utah state representative
i became aware of the fact that that
this issue
existed when i asked the question
to chief brad hennig chief what can i do
for you
and he said he started explaining to me
this issue and i was like
really because i thought
i thought this was an essential service
too i didn't know any better
yeah of course he was surprised finding
out that ems
is not deemed essential it's like
finding out that most states don't
consider geese to be birds
that's what they are they have beaks
wings feathers they range shipped from
the sky
sully sullenberger is their jeffrey
dahmer they're birds
i didn't realize anyone was even
disputing that
ems providers can be so strapped for
cash especially
in rural areas that they have to
fundraise for themselves
do a quick search on gofundme right now
and you will find
multiple outfits trying to raise money
for equipment gear
and updated ambulances and you know our
healthcare system
is up when patients and providers
are relying on the same crowdfunding
platform
some people even do fundraising stunts
for their local ems whether it's
this guy doing a polar bear plunge for a
thousand bucks
or this dj doing a three hour live
stream that raise money for ems workers
in new york and i have to say
my admiration for that man's generosity
is almost enough
to overcome my horror at the idea of a
three-hour livestream dj set
it's like someone donating a million
dollars to cancer research by writing
out a check in turtle blood
love the end hate the means
and these massive funding deficiencies
start to explain why it is that ems
workers
like that guy you saw earlier are so
terribly paid
the median annual wage is just over 36
well below what police officers and
firefighters make and
for a dangerous and stressful job emts
and paramedics have an injury rate about
three times the national average and
they're roughly 10 times more likely
to have suicidal thoughts or behaviors
so it is no wonder
that ambulance services can have real
trouble finding or retaining
workers and volunteers especially in
rural communities
experts now warn that close to one third
of all rural emergency medical services
are in immediate danger of closing down
in rural marmot north dakota
no one remembers the last time the town
had a doctor the ambulance is the
community safety net
we are literally one person away from
closing if we lose one of our emts one
of our care providers
we will have to look at shutting down
and closing our doors that is
terrible no workplace should be in
danger of shutting down because it loses
one person
unless that is that workplace is the sex
and the city reboot
what are you thinking it's never going
to work without kim control it's not
that any of you or bad is that you only
work
together i can't appreciate my puritan
charlotte if i don't have my naughty
samantha i know i live for miranda hobbs
but if she's not serving side eye while
samantha uses penne pasta to describe
her
new italian lover's dick what is the
point
and to be clear this isn't just a rural
problem
some big city services are stretched to
breaking point too
takes chicago where its ems is operated
by the fire department
both workers and city officials have
complained for years
that not enough resources have been
allocated to ems leading to an
ambulance shortage and while the fire
department says its fleet
meets the needs of residents a local
news investigation found some pretty
harrowing stories one analysis of 700
000 medical in nineteen 911
of them it took an ambulance more than
seven minutes to get to the scene
sometimes there just isn't one
wow we are out of ambulances
that is just not something you want to
hear i think we all know
when you call an ambulance you want it
to show up like that
what's wrong with you oh no i'm sorry
george i did it again
i'm sorry how hard is it not to snap
your fingers you know what
it turns out it's surprisingly hard you
know i got the power
to just clap my hands and summon kermit
the frog anytime i want
do you think i use it no i do not
because i respect
kermit yeah yeah i get that but uh hey
george
do it do it now please
this better be good george it's not
well i thought that went very well
anyway
um where were we oh that's right
emergency medical services in america
are underfunded because
in most places they're not supported by
federal programs and local dollars
the way that police and fire departments
are and the fact they
are so underfunded starts to explain why
they can cost
so much because for many the way they
recoup their costs
is by billing patients although
interestingly if they don't
physically transport those patients to a
hospital they can be out of luck
you're reimbursed based on the number of
patients that you transport to a
hospital
so you could get called a thousand times
a year and only transport 750 patients
those other 250 calls you made no money
on yeah it's true and policies like that
can not only put ems providers
even further into a financial hole it
can also incentivize them to take
patients to the hospital even if
it is not totally necessary which makes
no sense it's a practice known
throughout the ems industry as
you call we hall which i admit is a fun
phrase although to be honest
nowhere near as fun as the fire
department's motto you hurt
we squirt and ems's funding structure
doesn't just serve providers poorly it
serves patients poorly too
because right now patients and their
insurance reimbursements
are most ems outfits primary funding
sources which is just
not a good situation for either side
some patients have
medicare and medicaid and by law ems
providers
are required to accept their
reimbursement rates despite many saying
that they are set too low
but for patients with private insurance
the fact is
ems's are not required to accept that at
all
in fact many choose to keep themselves
out of network
for most insurers meaning that they can
generally set their rates
wherever they want this situation can
often leave patients facing so-called
surprise bills some of which can be
absolutely ridiculous
baby sawyer just couldn't wait to enter
the world katie marita's water broke
a week before he was due she and husband
daniel raced to sutter roseville with
the emergency room in sight katie
screamed for him to stop the car
don't push nathan i have to brush she
went like this and i pushed
and then popped and he came out
roseville pd called the paramedics
who cut the umbilical cord and drove
katie and sawyer a matter of a few
hundred yards to the hospital door
the entire time of the paramedics 10
minutes
it is such a blur but later it would
come into focus
when two equal amr ambulance bills
showed up one for katie
one for baby sawyer totaling more than 3
500 bucks
not even a full minute worth of an
ambulance ride we had already done the
hard part we delivered our child in the
front seat of our car
well hold on there did we
really do the hard part dan because from
what i just heard
you did some driving and then sat back
while your wife in your words
popped out a human so i'm not sure you
really
did the hard part so much as you were
just sort of there
come on dan be an ally read a tweet and
that can be absolutely crazy examples of
surprise billing even when ems is run by
the city
in houston literally all city-run
ambulance services are out of network
for all insurers and a study of one
large national insurance plan found that
of ambulance rides had the potential to
generate a surprise bill
and when you know that is it any wonder
that that woman
begged people not to call her an
ambulance or that this
incredibly grim trend has emerged
ambulance
or uber that's now the choice as more
americans are using uber and other car
services
to get to the emergency room 42 year old
tech magazine writer chandra steele did
it what were your symptoms
i had some
emergency room doctor robert glatter of
lenox hill hospital in new york
says uber er as it's been nicknamed is
not a smart idea in a crisis
they don't have any kind of oxygen they
don't have intravenous fluids or ivs
they don't have paramedics that's the
main difference they have a driver
right they also may not know which local
hospital has a trauma stroke cardiac or
pediatric unit because
they're uber drivers the most they have
are tiny water bottles you're afraid to
drink from and a charger for samsung
phone
you do not own so to recap
instead of all of us paying a little bit
all the time for ambulances
we have a system where some of us pay an
awful lot all at once
when we have a terrible emergency and if
you're thinking how could this possibly
get any worse well wait
it can because for-profit businesses are
also
involved here in fact currently private
companies represent about
25 of all ambulance providers and many
of them
are owned by private equity firms who've
been acquiring distressed local
ambulance providers
for decades now remember that baby who
got a bill for being born
that came from a private for-profit
company american
medical response they are currently the
largest ambulance company in the u.s and
are owned by one of the country's
largest private equity firms
and when a private equity firm swoops in
to help ring profits out of ambulance
services by keeping costs low and
revenues high
things generally don't change for the
better take
trans care an ems company acquired out
of bankruptcy by private equity firm
run by this woman lynn tilton and a few
things to note
about her aside from serving looks that
can only be described as
my style icons are wayne newton and a
ferrero rocher candy
lynn tilton is a self-described poet
already one of the
biggest red flags imaginable we looked
and one of the only things
close to poetry we could find from her
was this instagram post
i am a woman of strength nothing can
break my spirit
i am wild and free i am a warrior of
light
i am me which feels less like real
poetry more like someone with a
concussion trying to remember kesha
lyrics
lynn tilton was also the star of the
sadly cancelled reality series
diva of distressed where she portrayed
herself as a
savior of troubled companies in
inspirational moments like this
one of the things we do is we all commit
so i'm going to ask you all to commit
with me
that we will not stop until we have
achieved our goal
i commit
thank you commit commit
no in my mail she seems
great and lin tilton certainly knows how
to instill a sense of courage in those
around her it reminds me of that famous
fdr quote the only thing we have to fear
is in my mill and tilton
promised to bring that
uplifting leadership style to trans care
but many who worked there described
rough conditions on her watch with one
former employee saying
they were sent out in a vehicle where
the brakes didn't work properly
and during the 2014 ebola scare had
trouble getting enough sanitary wipes to
disinfect their ambulances
former staff even said they were
pressured by trans care supervisors to
go
er shopping meaning they would steal
medical supplies
from the ers to restock their ambulances
and when trans care inevitably ended up
filing for bankruptcy in 2016
its employees found out that they lost
their jobs like this
workers were told they had 30 days left
on the job they showed up
today to find this trans care
was shuttered i was in shock
we were all in shock it was horrible
it's absolutely horrible
a work emergency for dozens of
paramedics now i have to find another
job
i have another side job to support me
right now currently
but that doesn't pay the bills last
night we were told
see you tomorrow have a good night well
that's up
there are certain businesses you assume
might disappear overnight like a kids
lemonade stand or
any circuit city in the late 2000s
incidentally they all became
kingdoms of optical cables and loose
batteries governed by rats and that's
absolutely fine but it is not great when
what's disappearing is a community's
life-saving medical service
and it is not just the trans-care folded
it's that in a bankruptcy court ruling
last year a judge recommended finding
lynn tilton
liable for nearly 42 million dollars for
stripping value out of the company which
i guess
isn't totally shocking from a woman
whose employees were encouraged to strip
value out of emergency rooms
now i have to say tilton denies having
done anything wrong and has challenged
that recommendation
in federal court and the thing is i'm
not just
mad with lynn tilton here i'm mad that
we're operating a system where a vital
service is left vulnerable
to the lin tilton's of the world so what
can we do about this well
as i've said before ideally we
transition to a medicare for all
approach but that doesn't seem to be in
the cars right now and in the meantime
there are smaller things that we could
and should do
for patients we need to put an end to
surprise billing and the good news is
congress passed a bill last year called
the no surprises act making it illegal
to send patients steep medical bills
when an out-of-network provider is
unexpectedly involved in their care
the bad news is while that applies to
air ambulances the bill
for some reason explicitly carved out
ground ambulances in other words
most ambulances as for ems
providers
we should establish a lead federal
agency dedicated to them
and they should absolutely be labeled an
essential service especially because
that's what everyone thinks they are but
for that label to mean something it has
to come with funding at the local
state and federal levels and there is no
better time
to make these changes than right now
when we still remember the
absolute hell of what these workers went
through last year
remember that parade that bill de blasio
promised it actually took place
last month but you know who notably did
not attend
emts many of whom boycotted it because
of stagnant wages and the fact
that they worked during the pandemic
without hazard pay
look last year everyone was anxious to
show
just how much they supported emts well
now
is the time to prove it and make
big changes on their behalf
and if we do do that maybe we'll
collectively be worthy
of a siren that sounds like this
get yours mickey you filthy mouse
you